good evening everyone thank you and
welcome to you Elizabeth house my name
is John Kerr padam the policy manager
here at strata District Council my team
is responsible for adopting implementing
SIL colleague Randy Williams in
assisting in that and also I got mark
Fairgate and Nora Eastern consultants
who and working on steel for us
markers sort of seen it right through
from the very beginning where we did the
the technical work to underpin and
inform the the SIL rates that we are now
charging ought to say this is the second
of three sessions we've been running for
parish councils we've had one earlier
that's really well attended and one more
tomorrow morning so it captures some
more of your colleagues we're tending
then I would say it is being recorded so
we want to put it on the website so if
those who can't make it the sessions can
also see it and learn about SIL if I can
ask if you do want to ask a question if
you can use the microphones and we need
to do is just press the button the
bottom white for the light to come on
and then speak into the microphone but
not too close then they should work
fairly well we've got about two hours
for the session this evening hopefully
we won't need the full time but if if we
do that's fine if you've got any
questions we will do our best to answer
them mark is there is an expert so any
tricky ones please write to him and if
we can't ask them what we do we'll take
a note then circulate via email perhaps
if I can ask you to well mark all as it
goes through the presentation here
Paul's a certain time times and then our
questions on this section is just
covered rather than if we keep diving in
he just perhaps flows a bit better
and we may well cover what you're asking
in those sessions in those slides I
ought to just say that much of sue is
governed by government regulations so we
are slightly limited
to what we can do and being government
regulations they they are what they are
there then they're not perhaps the the
ways or best well worded regulations or
or text they're open to a bit of
interpretation in terms of the session
say Martin we're going to run through
the presentation there are some
exercises we're going to ask you to do
so you will need your thinking caps
possibly calculators in terms of
housekeeping toilets are through the
doors to your left
tea and coffee machine is just the door
to your right we're not expecting a fire
alarm if it does sound either through
this door turn to the right to reception
or through the door you came in on back
to reception then we reconvene in the
car parked behind the pub any mobile
phones please turn those off be
appreciated and lastly there is a
sign-in sheet if you can I should just
assign that and just make sure you've
all got handouts there's been going
around and there's also a feedback sheet
if you can ask you to fill out at the
end and return I'll be smashing okay
thank you very much I'll hand over to
you tomorrow
thank you thank you John as still is now
in place we thought it's a good
opportunity to sort of invite the
passion and the town councils to come in
and help to explain how SIL works and
what benefits it will have for your
particular town and parish councils so
the aim of the workshop really is to
sort of explain some of the basics
around SIL provide you the opportunity
to ask questions so as John said I'll
Paul's at various moments to give you
the opportunity to to ask what's what's
pressing off on your mind that
particular point but it is also a bit of
an interactive session so I will be
looking for you to do some thinking as
well and whilst it would be appreciated
phones are off you may need to switch
them back on to do some calculations
depending on how you mental arithmetic
is doing at the moment so in terms of
what we're going to do today first of
all I'm going to outline some basics
about what actually the community
infrastructure levee is then run through
the rates that are in operation now in
in Stratford and then sort of go through
some of how still actually operates in
practice some of the rules how they fill
out forms and how how how the town
parish councils will be involved in that
process and then finally we will be
looking at the spending which is
probably the more interesting part of it
for you so what sorts of things your
proportion of any SIL money can be spent
on how that works in practice and then
looking at a little bit about your
responsibilities and how you might think
about prioritizing how you spend any
money that you may well receive at some
point in the future so in terms of
watching what the community
infrastructure levy is some of you may
or may not be familiar with it but I'll
just run through a little bit of some of
the sort the main elements of it first
of all it's a standard charge of charge
on a per square meter basis so this is
very different from section 106 which
you may have been privy to in the past
which were all about a negotiation
between a developer or landowner and the
council in terms of what infrastructure
would be needed to make that development
happen how much that infrastructure
costs and what the contribution would be
from the developer that was all that
kind of a discussion between the two
parties to which n of 106 would be drawn
from sales very different in terms of
it's a it's an upfront known charge so
anyone coming into this district now
will know exactly how much SIL they will
have to pay for their development so
there's no negotiation it's a set amount
so there will be a familiarity before
they start making deals on land or any
of
things they'll know what the expectation
from the council will be in terms of the
SIL charges
so the SIL charges themselves they
relate to size of the development so how
many square meters it is and also what
type the development that is so what use
that development is going to be whether
it's going to be housing retail
employment etc there's a range of
charges which I'll go through in a
moment and they vary according to those
uses and also according to where they're
located within the district and as I
said they're charged at a per square
meter rate so for every square meter of
that development there's a separate and
then the times up by how many square
meters against that particular rate
could I just ask you a question gross
internal or gross external it's the
great internal area gross internal thank
you yeah the intention of SIL when it
was introduced by the government and a
while ago back in 2012 think at first
was first mooted was there to sort of
provide this certainty about the about
the contribution so everyone knew what
it was what it was going to be so
there's no there's complete clarity
about it it has been muddied slightly by
the fact that there's still section 106
is still abouts and still uncertainty
over those elements but I'll go into the
differences between those and a bit
later in the presentation the intention
is is for still to pay for or contribute
towards infrastructure to support new
developments but it's not there to
remedy existing deficiencies so it's
there to support new schemes new
development to help support the
infrastructure in that in that area so
I'll just pause there see if there's any
other questions over about what SIL is
yes starting the clean sheets of paper
absolutely I'll go through a little bit
about section 106 and the differences
between the two
to help that tell that process okay oh
sorry can you hear me yes so I was
waiting for something and so it's not
for extensions or anything like that
it's just new hat new houses or shop so
it's it's a mixture of things it's it's
all new development and it does include
houses yes but it would include
extensions if they're over 100 square
meters I'll come back to some of those
elements in in a second
thank you okay so this bill was adopted
by the council in December 2017 and it
was implemented February this year so
it's already in place so planning
applications coming forward now are all
subject to the SIL regulations and will
be expected to contribute to SIL so it's
already happening and will will continue
to until the council decide they don't
want to continue with it anymore so in
terms of the actual rates so these have
been through a process of public
examination and have been approved by a
examiner and then approved by the
council subsequently there's a range of
rates as I said depending on the type of
development where it and where it's
located so I'll just run through these
with you now so first of all we've got
the two strategic sites in the district
those are the ones that gave in
Lightborn Heath and Long Marston through
the process examination it was decided
that those are best dealt with still
with section 106 only so the SIL rates
for those will be zero the next one now
is the canal quarter and Stratford
so there the SIL rate any development in
that area residential development will
be expected to pay eighty five pounds
per square metre and then everywhere
else in the district it will depend on
the size of the development so for small
sites of want
ten units they will contribute 75 pounds
per square meter and then all over sites
of 11 or more residential units will be
150 pounds per square meter you all see
notice there's quite a big difference
between those two figures and that's
mainly due to the fact of efficiencies
of scale in effect that the larger
developers can purchase their goods and
their labor a much cheaper price than
the smaller developers and therefore
that has shown a difference in where
those two figures are set that's the
reasoning for that the next two on there
are sort of housing for older people so
we've got extra care housing and that's
the same as the other residential rates
and then we've got retirement housing at
zero the difference between those two is
that extra care housing doesn't have to
pay affordable housing whereas
retirement housing does have to pay
affordable housing towards so because
retirement housing also has to
contribute to the affordable housing it
was showing it wasn't viable for it to
also pay for a sill the other type of
development there is retail development
so in our town centers if the shops
developed in there which is very unusual
for a lot of significant amount of new
floor space but nonetheless if they do
develop they won't have to pay any sill
charge they are zero rated out of Center
development so this would be like Tesco
or Sainsbury's outside or a new retail
park for example or an extension to all
those retail parks they'd have to pay a
hundred and twenty pounds per square
metre any retail development within the
two strategic sites they'd pay ten
pounds per square metre all other forms
of development are zero rated so we
wouldn't have to pay any sylph so things
like employment for example it wasn't
found they were viable enough to
warranty silt charge on them so those
are all 0
any questions on on those rates
could I just ask if pending applications
are going to be section 106 or SIL if
they haven't had a decision notice they
will be subject to SIL so even if
they're in the system and they haven't
been determined yet they won't be
subject to civil now yes okay thank you
yeah
well I should also say is that these all
these figures are index-linked so every
year the council will look at a national
index that's prescribed by the
government and they will either up those
figures or lower those figures depending
on what the index is doing and although
having said that since SIL got bought
into place in 2012 and otherwise of the
country I've never seen the rates go
down so they've always gone up and last
year they're around about 8% over the
year so if we'd have introduced SIL this
time last year they'd be another 8% on
each of those figures so it does make
quite a big difference and in fact the
index that the government uses for this
purpose actually runs quite a bit ahead
of inflation so the likelihood is that
these will go up year-on-year certainly
for the moment anyway yes as regards
gave them night on heath and long master
no there's zero rated because you know
of those areas what did you find out
suppose you decided to need to expand
those areas what would they come under
at the moment if they were beyond the
areas that are identified they would be
up whatever the rural rate is probably
so it'd be the hundred and 150 however
if there's going to be significant
changes that in the future that'll
probably be through a local planner of
you and we know those that that's quite
a lengthy process and I think by the
time that process was done the council
would probably look at reviewing sill
rates as well to see whether it would be
something that they would continue
see when I six on or whether they would
change a position and look for silver
those sites so it would be something
quite a long way in the future I think
it focus that was that yes
what about affordable housing if said
there was a development and they had a
proportion of affordable housing on it
does that have a sill rate on it the the
development as a whole would have a sill
rate imposed on it if if part of the
development was affordable housing so
say ten percent of the units were
affordable units those that ten percent
wouldn't have any silk charged on it
that's exempt from SIL so the other
ninety percent would but not ten percent
right it's just didn't say it on their
own yeah I'll I'll come back to some of
the exemptions in a minute because
there's a few exemptions to SIL
so it would just get added to the total
cost at the end of me on my development
because we had a 12 and a half thousand
square foot house 116 square meters and
it was affordable who's to say what
affordable lease but say was two hundred
thousand I would I had eight thousand
seven hundred to the cost and the 8700
in terms of affordable housing would
have to meet the test of being
affordable housing as is defined in the
planning rules so first of all it have
to be a genuine affordable housing unit
so those are those set definitions that
set by government what classes as that
there is obviously always a question of
market housing is it affordable or is
even affordable housing afford to pull
to some people because of the incomes
but the definitions would be used in
terms of saying what's the affordable
housing element and what's the market
housing element and the silh would just
apply on the market housing element okay
this maps in your pack all its just to
illustrate really is that we've got the
different areas it's still applying in
one two and three there and the outer
cent of retail that if you want to look
at more details of which still would
apply where it's all on it's all on the
council's website so in terms of also
yep it's it's a mixed answer to that for
me and it's actually very helpful
question because it is part of the next
slide so in terms of what what cell
applies to and when it doesn't apply
first of all it applies to all buildings
all new buildings that people normally
go into now that is a bit of loose
terminology and as John said the
government haven't been entirely helpful
in the way they've written the
regulations around sill and that is a
direct quote from the regulations
obviously that can be interpreted in in
numerous ways but the sensible way of
looking at it is buildings that people
normally go into are things like houses
employment retail so I think we just
need to sort take a sensible definition
of what that is meant by the sort of the
two types of development that still
applies to would be anything that's more
than a hundred square meters so if a
shop wanted to extend for example and it
was putting on a big new unit that was
over a hundred square meters then so
would be charged on that increase
however if it was just putting say a
canopy on the front of the shop unit and
that was only ten square
eaters there would be no sill charge for
that because it'd be under the hundred
square meters the other type of
development is all dwellings so all new
dwellings would be still liable even if
they're under a hundred square meters
the exceptions that who is extensions to
existing dwellings so if you've got an
existing dwelling and you build a very
large extension that's over a hundred
square meters you'd be charged still if
it's under a hundred square meters
you wouldn't be charged so when I talk
to the DM officer when we were doing the
members training last week he said I
think there were about two or three
applications in at the moment there were
actually above a hundred square meters
so very large extensions to houses so
those would be subject to silt in terms
of redeveloped type sites if if it's a
subdivision of an existing house so
you've got a large house and you're
subdividing into flats that's not still
liable so you can't you're not allowed
to take any sill from that if you're
converting something like former office
block or a warehouse into sill it is
liable but the developer is allowed to
offset the floor space that's already
there against what he's proposing so if
he or she is putting a new development
in annex increasing the floor space then
it will be liable for the silk just that
increased but they're allowed to offset
any existing floor space the it gets a
bit complex but the the the caveat to
that is they have to have that existing
floor space in active use so it couldn't
have been an empty building for years
and years and years and then they put in
the housing and then they expect not to
pay nice hill they would be expected to
pay so in that case but if it was a
building that had been in use in recent
times and they can prove that so it's up
to them to prove it then they can offset
that floor space for that development
and that applies to all types of sort of
redeveloped floor space if you like and
that also leads on to sort of permit
development because some of those things
would be permitted to that I mean you're
allowed to convert an office to a house
say without necessarily needing planning
permission to what we call permitted
development that doesn't mean it
wouldn't be liable for sill and as I
said earlier the beauty was sill I guess
against section 106 is it's
non-negotiable
and neither the council nor the
developer can ask for the Silph rate to
be changed so if the developer comes to
the counts and says there are I can't
afford seventy five pounds can I pay
seventy pounds instead can't do it and
conversely the council can't say well
this developers making loads of money
off this site I wanting to pay eighty
pounds per square meter it is what it is
in the schedule so there's no there's no
debating about what that is
it's based on all those elements we said
so over hundred square meters all new
dwellings but there are some exceptions
coming back to a couple of questions
that we had earlier on that so these
exceptions include self from custom
build so self this is these are sort of
government imposed exception so this is
not a thing the council's chosen to do
or chosen not to do these are in the
regulations it's a self and custom
building that is the first one and that
that doesn't necessarily mean people
getting dirty to you know building their
own house and and putting in the more
for themselves this can be a bit of a
wider definition of that so it just
means they've been project managing the
development if you like and have had a
significant involvement in it so if
they've done that and they can prove
that they are a self builder then they
wouldn't have to pay sill this was the
government the government introduced
this about three or four years ago I
think to try and encourage more custom
and self build into the market what that
nice having it's questionable about
whether it is encouraging it or not what
it does mean is that councils won't be
receiving as much little money
there is one caveat to the cellphone
custom-build
to try and stop developers sort of
trying to use as a way of not paying
sale is the person who puts in the south
and custom-build exemption has to live
in that building for three years if they
move within that time they have to give
the money the still money back in effect
although you have to pay the sill levy
so that will hopefully help stop it
being used as an excuse the other
exemption next exemption there is social
housing so affordable housing so if it's
affordable housing as part of a wider
scheme or affordable housing done by the
council or by another provider
you know the registered provider then
they are exempt from paying sale the
next two there are sort of charitable
uses so if a charity is building a new
dwelling so let's say some charity like
shelter so they're building a new house
for homeless people they wouldn't be
liable for sill
also if the charity has some land and
they're going to sell that land for
development and they put in that
development then any money they make as
long as any money they make of that gets
reinvested in that charity then again
they are exempt from SIL the final one
there is exceptional circumstances and
we had a little bit of discussion about
this in the last session but suffice to
say really exceptional circumstances
have to be exactly that they are very
exceptional and there's quite tight
rules into what counts as an exceptional
circumstance and the council has a
choice about whether it wants to accept
that or not and I don't think there's a
right of appeal for a developer to say I
want to I I think I'm an exceptional
circumstance and all the other places
I've worked out with which is quite a
few now none of them have had
exceptional circumstances
successfully through so because it's
such a tight thing it just doesn't
happen very often so in general most
people will have to pay sill unless they
they meet those sort of four categories
above or indeed are are different size
okay so I'll just pause therefore I move
on any thank you where you have the
social housing what happens is the
reduced market rate value house for
instance in Welford the beat must have
been some development and all bit for
instance for social housing they didn't
want to pick up the tab and but they
just hadn't got the money so a deal was
done with the developer whereby the the
houses were sold on to people who met
the criteria of living in the village
all have ties with the village at thirty
five percent discount ok technically
that's not social housing and if it was
a two hundred thousand pound house
twelve hundred and fifty square foot
which is only onion sixteen square
meters just over the hundred square
meter you mentioned that would add eight
and a half thousand pounds and therefore
it would make it not affordable so there
needs to be something on there for the
reduced market rate housing for local
people to stay in the local villages if
it's low cost market housing quickly is
technically not low-cost they're
actually market market value houses that
they were there discounted correct
because somebody like orbit a social
housing organization don't want to buy
them and then find tenants for them and
back to the point it wouldn't make it
affordable for people yeah we had
somebody in the village and we found
them a house that they met the criteria
and they used about managed to afford it
and I know full well they won't have any
node would find another nearly nine
thousand pounds extra if it's a low-cost
market home but it's still a developer's
completely the developers profit and in
the future it will just be on the open
market then that will be there'll be a
sale rate
if it's an affordable low-cost market
house which really means that that
benefits held in perpetuity then it
would be zero it would be exempt yes I
understand the the houses that were sold
locally they were discount discounted by
the developer at the insistence that
with the agreement of us as the Paris
cash yeah discounting to two hundred
thousand hmm
that house would then we've sold on at
market value less the discount that was
allowed so nobody can make a quick block
but then it would be exempt it would be
yes yeah just on about the charity thing
if the charities got a plotter land if
they sell the plot Alonso developer and
then the developer puts in plan
information that developers still play
pays sealed only if the charity is still
holding the land so sill is payable on
the landowner so it's wherever the
liability lies with the landowner so if
they are still the landowner and they
are a charity then they wouldn't pay so
okay but if they just sold the land to a
developer then the developer then
becomes liable just the point gentleman
behind me was was making Syl I'm sure
just reduces the land price at the end
of the day that's as simple as that so
that's a way to look at it the question
I want to ask you is when you're let's
say a build up decides to build on the
edge of the village is school and builds
houses on the school sites can they
contract out of being liable for sill
under those circumstances assuming that
the land just been sold
let's say the developers acquired the
land for them builds the school the
school move into it he then builds
houses on the school site and sells
those houses so it's like a Lance so
staging the school moving to bigger and
better and brand new premises yeah no he
would still be liable on the other ones
he does build no can he contract out of
it can the council make an exception
under those circumstances potentially if
there was an if that was considered
exceptional I'm not sure whether it
would be but will that go through a
cabinet or full council meeting who is
the authority to make such a decision
Marcus said they were very strict
criteria for whether development is is
exempt or also rather exceptional
circumstances can be demonstrated I
don't know whether enabling development
would constitute for that but we can
certainly all obviously build wouldn't
be subject to SIL because it's not not
doesn't work under that well it's an
exempt construction but you're giving
here the town of the village in this
context a brand-new school so if you
penalize the developer too much the
scheme may never work unless of course
that school was in-kind payment instead
of paying the SIL sorry and I think mark
is going to come on to this a little bit
later but but there are times when a
developer instead of handing over cash
as a still payment can do something in
kind so that could be an in-kind
potentially obviously that's quite
detailed in it I'm just picking up the
point you made actually right in the
beginning when you just just spoke about
there was kind of an influence I think
that still is somehow it
on top of the house prices you're
absolutely right it's a charge on the
land initially and actually we're sales
being bought in elsewhere it hasn't
affected house prices just to make that
clear but I haven't still it doesn't
suddenly mean all the house prices are
going to jump up because of sill house
prices may go up because of the market
but not because of not because of sill
ok moving stop me talking for a little
bit so I'm just gonna show some examples
of development for the moment and just
check whether you've all been hopefully
listening I'm just going to ask a few
questions about each these types of
development and just shout out when you
know the answer so would this attractor
sill charge so 20 dwellings scheme in a
rural location and what's the charge
next on formal housing good test go in
and out of Center location how much
self-build prompt
absolutely well caveated electricity
substation building why not some housing
in the canal water so moving on to sort
of a little bit of the the process if
you like I won't dwell on this too much
only just to say that when a application
gets submitted as of the 1st of February
this year it'll have to be accompanied
by a SIL calculation form so if it's not
with that form then the application
won't get validated clearly there will
be a slight lag in some of the ones that
are already in the system I'm going to
have to be be dealt with but for new
applications coming in they won't be
validated until the forms submitted the
forms relatively simple it's sort of in
shadow there I don't need to go through
the detail of it but basically it just
says what's your site what's your floor
space are you liable
are you not liable the planning officer
when they receive that and the forms
being validated will check that the
floor space is correct and that the
appropriate sill rate has been selected
against it to help people submitting
these there is a little calculator on
the council's website which will just
help people in trying to work out what
their sill rates and then following that
if if they are successful in getting
their planning permission the council
will then produce a liability notice
which will tell the applicant how much
SIL they have to pay and the stages in
which those are paid I'll go through
those in in a second so the liability
notice is basically the the invoice if
you like for the sill belt
there is plenty of guidance on the
council's website on that
there's a little guidance sort of
guidance to know that's linked with the
planning portal that says all the stages
an applicant has to go through to fill
in all these forms so it's fairly
self-explanatory although it'll take a
little bit to get used to I think most
people once they've done it once or
twice will be so moving on to actually
how the levy is paid it's as as Laura
said actually it's normally a cash
contribution but if the council so wish
they can take it as an in-kind
contribution so using that school
example is a very good one of where that
might be appropriate but in the main
most the time it'll be a cash
contribution so the developer as soon as
they put Spade in the ground will be
liable to start paying whatever that
contribution is it's actually within 60
days of the commencement of the
development so within three months of
the thun thun of it sorry two months of
them starting they will have to actually
have paid whatever that still liability
is now this is quite a big difference
from section 106 where it wasn't as
clear in terms of when payments are due
or and there's a lot of dispute about
this this is very set in the regulations
about when they have to pay that is
unless there's an installment policy and
I'll turn to John cos he always likes
doing this bit yes so it depends on the
overall SIL liability so if it's under
20,000 pounds payment is in full within
sixty days
22:52 equal payments 180 and 360 days
fifty to a hundred thousand pounds it's
25 percent 25 percent and then the
remaining 50 percent after five hundred
forty day so it is as Mark said a sort
time-based
process as opposed to the number of
units
completed but these these installments
are really only for larger sites and so
the council to agree that this storm of
policies is the right approach so
anymore
any questions on that and just a quick
one if they're going to and make a
payment in kind rather than in cash who
will actually be determining the value
of that if it's you know building a
village hall next to development or no
who will actually determine if that
means you go to an independent
arbitrator in those cases so those are
normally appointed by often by Rick's
the royalty charter surveyors who will
do an independent valuation on whatever
that bit of infrastructure is but you're
right to kind of point it out because it
is one of the potential areas where it
could cause issues about agreements
about how much a school is worth or how
much the land for a school is worth and
how you actually value that and how much
it's worth to us as in how much it would
have cost us to build it absolutely
there's all those factors are in place
so it's a bit more of a lottery
I'd have to say in terms of whether the
independent Assessor would come up with
but the options there for the payment in
kind is the still more locked down than
the section 106 was for example and a
developer that has been able to reduce
their affordable housing for example on
the promise of a doctor's surgery yeah
and then that doctor surgery doesn't get
built what would happen in the seal
structure of that if that doesn't if
that doctor surgery didn't get built
because the doctors weren't yeah plane
as as I understand it it would work in
the same way as a cash payment so as
soon as they are building the liability
kicks in so if they don't build that
facility then the council can take
actions against them straight away if
they if they don't actually do anything
bouncer so it is probably a bit stronger
I'd say than perhaps section 106 would
be okay so in terms of section 106 I
think we had a sort of a question about
about how the relationship between them
in terms of how this will operate
section 106 is still there so there is a
SIL regime and a section 106 regime the
difference now will be that section 106
regime is kind of reduced in what it can
ask for as opposed to what it could
previously prior to still being
introduced however having said that
there are still elements of section 106
that will remain completely unchanged so
things to do with non-financial clauses
such as construction management plans
that kind of thing they'll still be in
section 106 affordable housing will
still be secured through section 106 as
it is now but other financial
contributions will be scaled back so if
you look at it in terms of sort of
strategic infrastructure and
site-specific infrastructure the
site-specific infrastructure so the
types of infrastructure that enable the
development to happen so a good example
of that might be a roundabout to get
into a development or some other road
scheme to enable a site to get opened up
that would still be a very site-specific
measure and would still be continued to
be through the section 106 regime
however contributions to something like
health or education whilst important to
development would be scaled back in the
section 106 oh you wouldn't seek those
who section 106 because SIL would be
there for funding those elements
so generally infrastructure that doesn't
address the direct impacts of
developments will be through SIL we're
addressing direct impacts it will still
be through section 106 I think it will
become more apparent as that as the
process goes on to what the types of
things that we
Monday through section 106 and the types
of elements will go through SIL and what
a lot of councils have found is that
those things change a little bit over
time as they've introduced SIL and got
used to the processes because some
things crop up that might be better
dealt with 106 than perhaps SIL so those
things do morph over time so every case
has seen how the council operates to
start with and then reviewing that we'll
go back we'll go into a little bit more
detail later on what types of things the
district council can use their SIL
funding for and then how that relates
back to the section 106 we'll go through
some of that so moving on to the more
interesting elements of spending so
we've gone through a bit of the process
about how the SIL is generated so now
I'm just going to go a little bit more
about how it can get spent so first of
all looking at who sort of controls the
money initially it's going to be the
district council they'll control the
money coming in so their gain this is a
slight change the section 106 regime
where the county council for example
might have had a separate section 106
for contributions to education that will
no longer be the case any contributions
to education will come out the SIL fund
that the district council will control
so be up to the district council and the
councillors to decide whether they want
to spend that money on education or on
something else that's that's quite a big
difference from the current regime so in
terms of how they how the pot gets
calculated as we've discussed there's a
number of exemptions first of all so
there's some things that are paying no
SIL anyway and then there's sort of
things sorry some things that are paying
a zero rate which is an in effect isn't
no SIL and then there's other things
like affordable housing that are exempt
so they're all taken out of the pot next
the element is administration because
bringing in a system like this is
extremely costly for the
council initially all the setup fees
making sure the right financial
processes are in place and there's the
officers to actually deal with with
working out the sill levels so they'll
take and this is again in government
guidance that they're allowed to take up
to five percent of the SIL pot and then
finally there's the bit that you're
probably most interested in which is the
neighborhood proportion and this will
vary according to your location and I
will go on to that next
so in terms of the neighborhood
proportion first all the council will be
asking whether it's a formal parish in
town council area so that's kind of the
first element to look at if it's yes the
next question the council will be asking
is is there a neighborhood plan in place
because this will make a massive
difference to how much SIL any
particular area will get so you have a
map I think in front of you that shows
you which parishes around towns in this
area have neighborhood plans made and
which ones are in the process of having
those done and which are starting to or
which those who haven't done anything so
I understand the ones in sorting or ng
ready color those that are made so they
will be getting the full 25% of any Syl
generated in their neighborhood plan
area and that will be from now the ones
in yellow are to be made shortly so next
month from next month probably those
will be also receiving their 25% then
there's a number in green that are by
the right examination or due to the
examination very shortly so they will
have a few months wait but aren't too
far away from getting the full 25% and
then the other ones are a little bit
behind in the process or not started at
all so those will for the foreseeable
future be getting the lesser amount and
in terms of all the ones that are made
will be getting only 15% of the silver
seats but that 15% comes with quite a
big but that it's actually capped at 100
pounds per council tax dwelling in that
area so if you can give an example of
that if there's a thousand registered
dwellings in your in your in your parish
then the maximum amount of SIL you'd get
in any one year would be a hundred
thousand pounds so that's equivalent
possibly to about 50 dwellings or so
in forward so if it goes over that then
any of that sill receipt would go back
to the council so again it's another one
that it's sort of another pointer
towards trying to get your neighborhood
plans in place because you won't have
any of those limitations put on you
they'll just pause there if anyone's got
any questions about that yes the balance
of the money being 30% if you learn able
to plan in place goes where five for
admin 25 to the right district this so
it's 70% yes where's the 70% go that's
that's for the district council for what
purpose or infrastructure so they have
to they've got a lot tighter rules we'll
come on to it in a moment but very
briefly they have quite tight rules on
what they can spend the money on parish
councils and town councils have a wider
scope to spend their money and we'll
we'll come back to those differences in
a bit but essentially yet that will go
to the district council for
infrastructure provision and notice at
that say almost raffia district is
perished but not every parish has a
formal parish council so it's it's where
there's a formal parish council in place
there that organization would get the
funding if is the parish without a
parish council the district council
would would manage the spending for that
parish
so another little exercise make sure
we're all still awake huh I'll give you
five minutes to do this so what I want
to know so we've got a development here
of ten units in a village I'm not
confusing it with any affordable housing
so it's ten market dwellings each unit
is a hundred square meters so if you can
tell me what the total sale liability is
then tell me if there's a neighborhood
plan how much the town and parish
council would get then if there's no
neighborhood plan what's the maximum
amount of SIL that they could receive
from that development and then finally
if there's a town and if there's no
neighborhood plan in place but there's a
hundred registered dwellings and they've
already received ten thousand pounds
from SIL this year what would they
receive I'll give you a couple of
minutes
aside from
[Music]
as the study seemed to have stopped some
Schumi we we all done yeah okay so can I
have a volunteer to answer the first
question
totals Silla ma'am excellent stuff they
got these alright in the earlier session
so hopefully you will as well
no no pressure so if there's a
neighbourhood plan and if there isn't a
neighbourhood plan what's the maximum
and if there's already received ten
thousand pounds and you're in a non
neighbourhood plan area
excellent stuff you you've passed with
flying colors
I'm glad to say I think after maybes a
bit harder actually the tomorrow morning
I'm gonna make them really tricky
there'll be some offsetting I think okay
so I'm going to pass over to Laura now
to take you through the next sections of
our discussions oh sorry yes if
somebody's got outline planning yeah and
they were about to put him for full
planning yeah well they fall under sit
or not if they've already got outline
planning they won't be so liable now
okay another one if somebody puts in to
extend their house by ninety square
metres and then it gets approved and
then the following year they put in to
extend it by another forty square bases
unfortunately same answer they would be
they wouldn't have to pay however having
said that and this comes up a little bit
in terms of thresholds as well so where
we've got our ten dwellings and our
eleven dwellings and the difference in
sill rates there similar circumstance
could happen where a developer builds
ten at the lower rate and then the next
year he puts in for another ten
what the planning officers will be doing
and monitoring quite carefully is where
they think developers are trying to pull
a fast one and do that kind of thing and
try and rein it in before they even get
to the point of making decisions so if
they feel the site should be twenty
dwellings and the developer is only
trying to do ten dwellings and they will
say they're not going to accept that it
can also the sill rate not the rate but
the total value change so if they want
to build five houses they put into the
planning and then they decide to change
the design a little so all the houses
are ten square meters bigger we need
knock on their door and say excuse me we
need to add something to the sill if
they're increasing floor space yet they
would have to pay the full amount yeah
and just floor space include the garage
yes it does okay any other questions
don't get the up to five percent of the
silver seat is going to charge the whole
five percent in all cases the council's
looking to being controlled by the
district count so instead of county
council education for example previously
we you'd have to apply for that section
106 money to the county council and they
determine whether it is a necessary
project that they think is suitable will
the district do the same sort of control
over that money yes nothing in the next
slide where we come on to how the
district won't my spend answer I think
it's a question of the back as well yes
in our village as Debbie mentioned
there's a parcel of land that it's got
outlying Planning Commission and got it
under appeal to ten houses the developer
doesn't actually go in the land at the
moment they're still negotiating of what
houses better people alternate in the
style so the landowner still owns the
land although it has got out on Planning
Commission once the developers sorted
out exactly they're going to put
going for food planning so they don't
own the lands but therefore if they're
putting in for full planning they don't
own the land surely then Syl should
apply because they don't own the land
the sill liability is with the landowner
unless the landowner points that
liability to the developer so the land
ownership doesn't make any difference to
to the sill process if you like a
charity yeah unless your charity if
they've already got the outline planning
permission yeah unfortunately if if they
can't come to an agreement with the
landowner and that permission runs out
and they have to reapply then they would
be liable
we haven't mainly because it's quite a
can say that it's pretty strong word but
it's quite dangerous exercise to do that
because it puts perhaps expectation
about whatever the sills might be and if
they don't meet those expectations then
it causes almost more problems and
trying to work it out in the first place
it's because of the exemptions and we
don't know how many people will say
exempting custom-build in some areas has
been a lot of it in other areas there
hasn't been so much of it so we don't
know how Stratford is going to react to
that so we we purposely haven't done
that exercise because you simply don't
know what the answer would be
but overall do you think you'll be
better off than section 106 so somebody
asked that question earlier actually I
think in the balance probably yes
because section 106 is aren't entered
into so much for smaller developments or
all the amounts secured on smaller
developments isn't as much as would be
secured through sale time will tell
okay any other questions for we move on
okay thank you wait now now now you've
got a better idea maybe of how much
might be coming although that depends on
you name what developments in your area
I just wanted to talk a little bit about
what what it can be spent on so there's
the bigger portion there's the district
pot with which I'll just quickly outline
first the district have to spend their
portion of the sale a larger portion on
infrastructure in the area that's needed
to support development and by the area
I'm I don't just mean in the area of
development I mean in in the whole
district and that's fairly tightly
controlled they have they will have
published what's called a section one
two three lists that just refers to the
legislation and that covers the sorts of
things that they're planning to spend
their their portion of the civil which
will be infrastructure related to
development it varies by district across
the country but in stratford-on-avon
it covers a lot of things that you would
have seen on one section 106 before I
think we've mentioned this we've
mentioned doctor surgeries and education
and libraries
I think there's quite a bit of highways
in there as well and the council can
only spend their portion on those
elements that at the moment are in the
one to three list although it can be
reviewed and as I say it has to be
infrastructure needed to support
development in the area and they can't
fund affordable housing through it yes I
should have said the list is in your
pack it's right near the back of your
pack if I can just provide a bit more
detail on that so if your one two three
list there that's a sort high-level list
of the sort of types of infrastructure
weaves as District Council can spend
salon
sitting beneath that there's something
called infrastructure delivery plan
which is a much bigger spreadsheet
that's got specific projects listed and
the intention of the way the council was
agreed that we will spend the money is
we will review that IDP at least
annually and stakeholders service
providers parish councils can make
suggestions for infrastructure projects
to go on that list and then there'll be
a bidding round where service providers
and ward members on behalf their
communities can make bids for funding
for certain projects
so where is under the 106 regime the
county council for example education
signed a 106 the County Council will now
make a bid to the district council and
the district council will determine what
infrastructure is funded from his
available steel funds so puts the puts
the district council wing in control of
infrastructure spending in the district
for that it is at 70% off of the SIL
funding some of these infrastructure
projects you would be looking for other
funding from another source and would
you anticipate working with town
councils for the Town Council to
contribute some of those is that a
collaborative approach that you'd be it
could be yeah and I think it's from
understand where the pressing needs for
infrastructure spending is and if there
are certain projects that parish or town
wants to think should be delivered and
it could be delivered by some
neighborhood plan funding in some
district house funding then why means
it's something we'd consider here
but I think more importantly for people
in the room is what can the neighborhood
pop be spent on you a 25% or your 15%
you've actually got a freer rein than
the District Council have got the
regulations say that you can spend your
apportion it must support development in
the local area and it can be for the
provision or maintenance of
infrastructure but it can be anything
else that is concerned with addressing
the demands that the development places
on your area so it can be so if you
think about any sort of pressure that
having extra houses in your area creates
within your parish you can meet that
need by spending you can meet that
demand by spending your cell pot on that
item somebody was very interested before
they had a I can't a parish hall that
was a bit the aphid ated could they
improve their parish hall well yes if
the extra people coming to the area
means that there's more demand for using
the parish hall yes you can use your
cell pot for that sort of thing I also
said this morning the husband said could
I could we have a duck pond in a village
yes if that need for open space is
increased and you want and from the
demand that comes from the new
development so if you can relate it back
to the new development then then it's
it's something that you can be provided
you've got enough money you can spit you
can spend the funds on does that make
sense can you see the difference I'm
going to give you some examples in a
minute dude do you actually have to
spend your 25 percent or 50 percent in
that year or can you bank it because I'm
thinking of an example where housing
gets gets built me a prime more housing
in a village and you have to get to the
stage where the local primary school is
full can't support here to build a
school in the custody of fantastic
anybody that's a really good example yes
you can bank it and there is but there
is a limit on the amount of time
can keep it for which is five years
however there is some discretion in that
and if you knew there was another little
bit of money coming after five years
that would help you realize your project
then the council have discretion not to
insist on the five years on the five
year time limit so yes banking and
banking it is a good idea really few
answer if you want if there's something
like a school when exactly does the five
years start once it ends up in your
pocket yes okay how do we know where it
ended up in your pocket because it comes
it's paid six monthly and you get it for
the period prior to the six months
so what a relevant as a way of thinking
about it what I want you to do is call
out if you think these items are things
that you could spend your silver suits
on in your parish and then village hall
yep you can indeed repair or improve an
existing yeah affordable housing ah you
can in this case you can spend it on
affordable housing because you don't
have the restrictions that the District
Council has if if the pressure of
development is such that you think
perhaps in in future years there'll be a
greater need for affordable housing in
the village because of the new
households that will come in and then be
generated by the by the new housing then
you can use it to fund affordable
housing if you want it to new or
improved player is holidays appearances
sadly not preparation of a neighborhood
plan yes again yes and it had there have
been examples of this in other areas
again
the pressure of need development you may
make you feel that you need a
neighborhood plan either because there's
going to be more development and you'd
like to maximize the sill to spend in
the area all that there are things that
you would want to do for the community
as a result that are better met through
a neighborhood plan a cycle way yeah new
or improved Park air quality monitor
yeah so very good you can do all of
those things apart from the holiday and
then you say maybe even in the holiday
for it's causing you lots of stress
so it's important to think about how you
will spend the money and what you might
spend it on and those of the regulations
are a little bit loose it does obviously
require some thought process further
than some some consultation this all
sounds very obvious because I'm sure
you'll think like this saying maybe it
needs a beginning of thinking about what
your infrastructure needs might be in
your particular parish or your town what
extra demands will be placed on them by
the development that's coming up whether
it's ten units or fifty units or even
hundred you know that the pressures will
be different and there's an impact on
services too but at the same time
remembering that by receiving some self
funding it's not a replacement for your
everyday expenditure and if you if you
miss spending it on that holiday then
the council can claim it back and maybe
some parishes have found that drawing up
their own infrastructure plan that has
been helpful particularly where there
perhaps worked with the white community
to try to draw that up and you do have
some responsibilities and part of that
is just understanding what's going on in
in other areas and what's going on in
the district the regulations saying you
should have an understanding of wider
projects and knowing about those bigger
projects will help you think about what
you might want to spend the money on in
in your parish so for instance if you
know that there's a big service road
coming in you made no longer think about
that small roads that you wanted to
serve your village because there's
there's something larger that will deal
with that and you can spend it on
something else that's needed and also
the importance of thinking about the
cost
having that village green would be great
but there will be an ongoing cost
to maintain it so important to think
about how shall we how it works on going
and then relation you should use the
words in the guidance you should be
thinking about how you engage with the
community to determine infrastructure
it's how you make sure everybody's heard
that there isn't perhaps somebody with a
loud voice who plays cricket he thinks
the village needs a new cricket pitch
actually how will that serve the whole
community and or how can that be made to
serve the whole community I'm keeping in
mind all the time
the demand that's placed on it by the
extra buy the extra units buy the extra
housing that's coming and will it be
inclusive how do you include everybody
and the point made earlier about how the
funds can be maximized though there
might be a temptation to spend it really
quickly but in the long term something
like a school or contributing to a
classroom maybe even that classroom in
another parish would be a better use of
the money if if the school is going to
become oversubscribed and it's not
something that's going to be funded from
the wider sale pot and I've just been in
there you know just being aware of the
time it takes to accumulate funds and
maybe thinking also about the potential
to get funds from elsewhere and to match
what you've got or to match or matching
it matching it yourself from other
receipts that you've got as a parish
council or you might want to everybody
laughed at me love some but you might
want to contribute to one of the wider
projects that the District Council are
already losing skillful rather than
something in your own in your own parish
and and the example that that I suppose
I could think of is if you had a very
busy road going right through the middle
of your village you might actually
prefer to give your SIL pot back to the
district because they're building a
bypass and if you give your funds back
then that black-hearted will happen
quicker and there'd be relief from
trafficking
village obviously I had no idea if any
but it does have a very busy road going
through their village but that's a say
so you could you could spend it
elsewhere any questions we'll the
district counts will be auditing the
post Town Council's usage supposing the
amount of money that one got from silver
as a parish council would just say it
was ten thousand you actually your
project what you design everything for
cost nine thousand then spend it on your
second priority
yes well I think you'd need to if you
wanted it to go over five years you'd
need to have it earmarked for something
so say you've just built you village
hall and actually you've got a thousand
pounds left over and there's nothing
left to spend it on because it's
beautifully decorated and project it's
just that normally with something that
sort of size one would tend to sort of
rather than small items exchange a
attention one
was a bigger project they built for
something yes
enormous that it should be spent within
five years but obviously that's up to
them is team thank you
you'd have to ask and then in your pack
there's a sheet and we just wanted you
to I have to start thinking about some
of things that you would like to say
just still release them and another
thing actually another example I will
just give this because somebody asked
this this morning this could it be use
the staff and again the answer is yes
but if you could think perhaps about
some of the things that you'd like to
spend your silver seats on is there any
priority whether or not you've got any
idea about cost and whether you think
you will receive enough
excuse me white people are thinking on a
totally unrelated topic to do with money
again the government have brought this
in when will we be seeing the contribute
all our council tax reduced by County
Council District Council and the
precepts for parish council in light of
extra funding coming in which was never
allowed for from the castle tax rates
for fix over the last five or ten years
course with is money coming in to some
areas and also in others to the district
you're getting seventy percent of it to
spend on whatever you wish the pressure
on you is accounts or to reduce the
council tax and the commercial rates to
be getting a share of that shortly I
believe will be enormous but also the
council will be getting some of this
will be money that the council was
already getting through section 106 so
it's not it's not a complete central
government reduce their grants to you
all you and the county I think is
already reducing its grants to the
district and County Council's aware
which one defined budgets are resources
to to meet our existing expenditure I
think the thing was SIL this is
important to pay for infrastructure that
we were struggling to provide previously
so the district the seventy percent that
the district can spend as has been
outlined we've got a very narrow remit
on which we can spend it we can't spend
it on running our council as a but we
can we can only spend it on
infrastructure projects in their IDP but
you're saving money from somewhere else
sort of had to been found to spend it on
those projects he can be reallocated
somewhere else I think that the point is
that the one of the criticisms and this
is why she was brought in was the these
infrastructure needs weren't being met
sillies being introduced
to meet leave the structure deficit
that's there so I think it's important
to stress that it's not a way of
balancing the books this is new funding
to help result additional additional
things yeah yeah to meet the
infrastructure demands operative the
next flow some that is there's therefore
pressure on district comparison Town
Council's to support and the
applications rather than be negative
towards them because they're gonna get
some money out of it so say you don't
like that not a good hang on a minute
we're going to get 40,000 pounds of you
say yes I think we're saying yes on this
occasion it might be something you want
to think about yeah isn't it well I'm
being cynical but yes it's how people
will inevitably think
okay
you don't have to share anything but
anybody got any ideas they'd like to
share with everybody any things I'd like
to spend their extra so portion on some
planting maybe planting and there will
be there were going to be some parishes
that are going to get much more than
others because they've got more
development if you're in a restricted
yet nothing nothing much is going to
happen it does very huge change
and any other ideas things he'd like to
spend your money on and we're a burial
Authority
could we use it towards a new cemetery
and the associated costs I don't see why
not any development is going to place
and would that potentially have some
discretion associated with it if we
didn't get it up and running within five
years I mean there might not be anyone
buried in it in the next five years for
example but but there's no reason why
you should acquire the land
yeah we've we've got that we've got the
land I guess it's always it's it's
discretionary it would be down to the
council to to say in any other sigh here
I hear you wonder wandering off at the
back yeah any of anything else to do if
you was there anything you would
particularly want to spend yourself on
in youth services yeah yeah oh sorry
question no we'd like to improve our
sports facilities mmm this is well food
we were allocated we'll have to build up
to eighty four houses yeah we've had I
think an excessive passed off the
planning in excess of hundred and thirty
six so apart from changing the built up
boundary really squeeze any more into
benefit from any sell money but we would
just that we really would not and we
spoke about it a lot at the parish
council to improve the sports facilities
because the amount of families
the village that it's got a Ofsted rated
outstanding primary school
oversubscribed seems to make no
difference whatsoever for more people
keep piling in and we have a very
limited amount of green space yeah for
playground equipment for the case yeah
and what we have is by the school but
that's now full so we a new sports
facility is just just out of the
question is just too much money
that's not gonna happen even if we built
it with the school in including the
school in the plan so we could refurb
are existing they described as a port
thought Hut that would be more realistic
a mat it's used by at least ten junior
football teams every weekend the senior
team and the cricket club so it does get
really well used but the facilities are
appalling you'd be shocked especially
knowing that we've had 136 you and we've
been we haven't been it but we've had a
bit of section 106 money but we haven't
really benefited that much we bought new
playground equipment sure you thought
about other funding other things we'd
like to say wouldn't infrastructure -
for the roads because there's so many
houses being built the really big
bottleneck you don't get out and don't
get in get out the morning get in in the
evening yes
I mean all the house is going to be
built down at Long Marston and at the me
unveil it's going to get worse and we
don't see anything any light on the
horizon of the roads being improved
anywhere around the area I know this
plans for the relief road and so forth
but at what cost
are you getting the developer big
developers to pay for it and then you've
got the bridge going over the river by
the racecourse and chutneys to curry
house and all of that is going to be
such a long way off I guess in the
future
so we'll help parishes in this sort of
situation but but it does sound like
you've week sort of messing about you
this is kind of
he's long Mastan and gazing covered by
section 106 or they get why we think
Scott for yes no no they will be covered
by section 106 lot man was given a crowd
I'm sorry I don't I have no idea it is
had some funding from government schemes
as well thank you so we're near at the
end now but just with with the money and
just comes from rules
I think but really just to say that
parish councils do need to have proper
financial arrangements in place and they
have to record which I'm sure you will
already with public accounts and audit
legislation also that even if you do
some money you don't have to have it if
you don't want it you do have to tell
the council if you don't want it but you
don't have to receive it and I suppose
it's back to those examples maybe you'd
rather contribution the council they're
doing there's a small possibility of
that or maybe you're such a small parish
but you don't feel you can handle the
money it there aren't many circumstances
but you don't have to have it if you
don't want it normally as we've covered
a couple of times normally spent within
five years and all the District Council
could try and recover it you do have to
publish publicly what you've received
and what you've spent it on including
bits of information about projects that
you've funded if it's if it's not clear
and you receive the money you can come
to a different arrangement but normally
you receive the money from your SIL
receipts twice a year on the 28th of
October and the 28th of April for the
preceding six months
I just don't say that if if you decided
as a parish that you didn't want to
handle the spending and ask the district
counselor to do it that money would
still be spent in your parish it
wouldn't you wouldn't be lost the wider
area so we would we would act on your
behalf if if you didn't want to spend it
yes yourselves well he's only been
operational since February so for there
to be so monies at the moment you would
have to got permission since temporary
and then been implemented for the seal
to be liable so I think it's unlikely
the big thing you mean in 1819 so monies
will start to come forward who gets a
statement so is it just become through
the District Council I don't know the
exact how they'd be transferred over the
funds would be transferred over to the
College Council and when you apply for
it to just apply for it on one form and
say I want to use the money from ABC
place your money you lose your army so
it's but we need to tell you what we're
gonna well you publish your report on it
annually afterwards
so if if you've spent it on eggs and why
then you publish a report that says
we've spent are very much money on eggs
don't need to apply for it and tell you
what we want it for no no say give us
the money yes you're you you'll get the
money automatically twice a year there's
for you to spend it as you see fit and
then you report you publish a report
saying how you
I just thought it you looked after it
until we said we wanted it so we and
we're happy to do that
if you don't wish to but so you can you
can manage the accounts yourself they
come through we have obviously had some
investment and I don't think I've seen a
bigger on any of the paperwork that I've
had saying oh and the silky this one
would be X Y Zed is that just because it
by coincidence doesn't apply to any of
them or you know will that just be a
will that be really obvious on the
paperwork that I'm getting for each
application it should certainly be in
the case officers report how much seal
is liable I don't know if it's on the
decision notice i we could find out
their separate seal forms the
application so now whether whether you
get notified of those as well I can
confirm that to you to see what
information you you would use the same
here so phone final slide really to say
that still is now operating in this
district from February and we just
thought to say there will be some
initial confusion and particularly
perhaps from smaller developers I think
the big you know parrots or persimmon
look will be very familiar with it but
some of the smaller developers or
smaller landowners may find the process
a bit confusing
there's the council offices are here
encourage people to ask questions if you
don't understand
contact the planning department they
they do I believe have a team of people
who will be dealing with it it won't
answer so won't answer all the all the
infrastructure problems in the district
but hopefully it will help and I just
wanted to finish by saying that in the
press you may have seen that just
loosely or a year or so ago there was a
lot to talk about with the host
regime change and there has been a
government review of SIL we don't know
the outcome of it but us them speaking
to people at D CLG we don't think
there's going to be any major changes to
how it operates so those reports are old
really and relate to previous
governments but there may be some
tweaking there might be some tweaking to
it but it's I think it's gonna stay
largely Pazzis and that's everything we
say and you say it's the landowner
that's responsible for sale so at the
point of application I have to say
Fred's the landowner so photos got to
pay X but then if Fred sells it to Bill
as he got to tell you that actually I'm
no longer responsible for the sale bill
so yes I think it would depend on how
it's correct correct me if I'm wrong
from the council but so Fred owns the
land but bill is going to develop it and
Bill has an option on the land and Bill
has got the planning permission all the
work to get the planning permission Phil
isn't payable until that first Spade
goes in and that first Spade will go in
once bill is brought bought the land
from Fred so bill will be paying the
film okay but it's got a liability to
let you know who the landowner is so
frequent being Frank would be in in the
pay will be in the name does the
landowner
the the developer wants to he has put in
a new application which was turned down
so he could build what he originally had
permission for but that's not that's not
really viable because of the problems
he's discovered so I'm expecting that he
will put in a new application so will
it'll be a complete well I don't know it
might be completely different to the
first one so will that count as a new
application and be liable to fill a new
application regardless of what's gone
before an application with a material
material change it's almost what we had
before but it's you know if it's a new
formal application it would require it
would be subject to failure yeah
absolutely unless it and that's one of
those other exemptions apply but
generally speaking if it's in the
application he builds it and he sells it
to somebody else then
these things that developers will be
better off with for the sill perspective
tip from 106 I'm just thinking on it
could develop had a development in mind
would it be worth his while trying to
either rush it through before the 1st of
February or to be laid to laughter
that's what our still is already in
place that would have already have had
to have happened in other areas where
there's been a slightly longer lead-in
time between the council sort of
agreeing to go forward with sill and
then them implementing it it has
happened yes it has been a big influx of
applications have come in before the
sill has kicked in but here because it
was actually quite a short time frame
they have really had time to do that in
effect they could have made an educated
guess that the council would approve it
yes absolutely okay if there are no
other questions can I just thank you for
your attendance your time this evening
can I thank mark and Laura for their
presentation hopefully you found it
interesting in the lightening
informative and it's useful certainly
we've put one of the webcasts on on our
website with the presentation so you
have to receive it and pass it on to
colleagues the website address is
[Music]
www.fafsa.ed.gov packs if you wouldn't
mind just filling those out just helps
us with future events and so forth
but lastly just thank of you time and
good evening